good morning where are we monkey where
are we going
yeah no dude okay so yeah we're gonna
get breakfast but after that what are we
doing
We're not gonna go dancing we're gonna
go to the
we're gonna go on a hike to go see some
snow
why are you so mean
okay so we're on the way Mia
hey baby yes
I'm gonna use a fart and then
something's like weird happening okay
fine okay so we're Papa's in California
not surprised I feel like I see that
every Vlog
um so he's in California and
um tyke and I are gonna go on a hike so
we're getting breakfast like he said
hopefully there's snow there so I'm
prepared for the snow but we're just
dressed for a regular hike in 40 degree
weather below 40s
um also because Mia has been riding in
my car every day now like anytime I go
pick or drop tech off from school pick
him up from school
um yeah she comes with me she's like my
dog she's my doll she's Tyga's dog
and she unless she's dead she's dead
yeah there's a lot of dog hair been
accumulated here so now I ride
with this
and every time she gets out and I get in
I vacuum
I'm a freak but I just hate dog hair so
I have my little Roomba my little eye
robot constantly running at home like
every single day it's just vacuuming
because I know what it's like living
with German Shepherds never live with a
husky but I can only imagine it's just
as bad yeah so I know they can
accumulate really really fast so I have
to maintain it every day look at this
wait wait wait
look at the snow
that's what we're going monkey mans
no way way way way
we've only been on the road for like 20
minutes look at what look I took a
picture of me and I was on this guy's
face oh what are you gonna do are you
gonna punch her
yeah it's not nice
that's not nice
look I'm driving I'm not even looking at
the camera as I film you right now
we just got here and this dude fell
asleep Midway so now I'm just kind of
cruising
and checking out the houses here Dan
this house is tight it's all blacked out
so sick
I'm like riding my brakes that's not
good
I don't know how where I'm going
to like oh look at a wow
but I like what I'm saying now what I'm
saying
I love it do you love it Mia you love it
I love it I think I found a Local's only
spot it's like in the cut
and it's just like less than 10 cars are
here
I think I did it I don't know what it's
gonna look like on the other side but
this is this area has seen like the one
that's been the furthest away from
everyone and so far it looks okay but we
won't really know
until we get out there no won't we
no the question is sure up
and let him sleep
I think I'm gonna let him sleep
we got the dude that's sinking and we
got Mia
what okay come down let's go see what's
on the other side
this is gorgeous
well I would I would keep my dog on a
leash however I forgot my leash can you
come
I should have bought a leash for this
guy too just kidding come on let's play
dude
tiger found a Snowman and it doesn't
look like the snowman's gonna live very
long huh
while it's been here a long time
ago a couple weeks ago okay I'm gonna
take a picture of you oh there it goes
I didn't get the picture
here come
yeah
okay girl yeah
yay
I wonder how long your paws will last
like that we'll play it by ear
oh my God there's so much going on on
both directions
get me
home come here
good girl
he went all the way up there and slid
back down huh get her yeah get her get
me a bag
oh Mia cup
good job good girl
yeah
hold on me let's go nuts
oh somebody carved on it that's a bummer
oh my God I just my whole foot just sunk
I forgot my snow pants okay I gotta go
see where Tyco is
okay this is a real snowball monkey oh
shoot I'm sinking oh my God oh my God
this is so fluffy oh yep yeah look yeah
no I want to see it
look at that one so cool wait don't mess
it up
yeah
so we are back home and don't be fooled
that's not the flamingo I'm talking
about taika so right now it's Saturday
Titan do you normally train Jiu Jitsu on
Saturdays
no you don't and you know what I'm so
proud of you that you're training so
tyco's actually going to compete in his
first BJJ tournament
um it's gonna be next Saturday so a week
from now and his coach requested that he
did he do a private lesson
um so he can just get the techniques
down and all the secret words and
taika where are you serious
and taika is gonna do it and he's happy
to do it he's not complaining not one
complaint can I hold the camera yeah not
one complaint from The Young Tykes
[Music]
give me that okay thank you
hey monkey I'm really proud of you dude
I think you're so awesome
God damn it
I taught taika how to FaceTime
us and now he's been calling he only has
three numbers me Papa and Grandma
okay monkeys did you see me
so now and Papa's in Sacramento right
now I'll probably think competition
and I'll explain more about why he's in
his ghee and how he's